on a plutôt l'habitude d'y voir des
militaires en entraînement où des
plongeurs mais ce jour là au cap la
houssaye petit ans de rêve sur la côte
ouest ce sont deux charmantes sirène qui
s'apprête à se jeter en plein grand bleu
entre 2004 et 2006 je faisais partie de
la compagnie dragonne et on a créé un
spectacle qui tourne encore au jour
d'aujourd'hui à las vegas qui s'appelle
le rêve donc j'ai fait partie de ce
casting là pendant pendant deux ans
pendant deux ans j'ai habité à las vegas
et travaillé au théâtre de monsieur win
tous les soirs je suis revenu à la
réunion en 2006
cette nageuse conduite par marie tav nar
membres du comité régional de natation
et ex nageuse de la célèbre compagnie
dragonne qui produit les choses
aquatiques les plus démesurées a fait
entre 19 et 25 ans qu'on fait de la
natation synchro donc c'est vrai qu'on a
un énorme bagage technique derrière nous
et soit que c'était une sortie
exceptionnelle pour nous parce que c'est
la première fois qu'en nager en milieu
naturel et
en mer donc tous les repères étaient
vraiment différent de la piscine
présente session exceptionnelle en plein
océan
du grand art rien que pour tes yeux
public de sensations sport
il ya beaucoup de fonds n'y a pas de
paroisse sur les côtés il ya un petit
peu de clapot
la visibilité est pas non plus
parfaite comme en piscine donc c'est
vrai que c'était super différents
c'est hyper intéressant et c'est
enrichissant aussi parce que d'habitude
on se rend compte qu on se repère
beaucoup par rapport à la piscine et
lens se repérer entre nous donc c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant
et puis pour les porter aussi on s'est
rendu compte que le fond de la piscine
il aidé quand même beaucoup
elle
e
je
et
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de qualités à
avoir pour la natation synchro notamment
faut déjà savoir très bien nagé en
natation pure il ya tout une question
aussi de souplesse de grâce donc à
l'apnée la force aussi pour sortir les
gens bord de l'eau
à la coordination le sens du rythme il
ya tout un tout un petit panel de
qualités physiques à acquérir
et hop
parent
elle
ben
m
mais
on fait plusieurs spectacles par an le
prochain en fait c'est pour l'occasion
de la nuit de l'eau donc c'est une
opération lancée par la fédération
française de natation qui est national
c'est pour récolter des fonds pour
l'unicef
et je fais un gros bisou aussi à toute
l'équipe de sensations sport
n'est ce pas
si on m'avait dit
comment